you're arguing with him you forget he's
your boyfriend and the way you're seeing
it is oh you're screwing up to me so I'm
going to square up to you this
relationship and nothing goes out the
window uh he's trying to prove a point
but no this is the point that I think
um so so yeah absolutely it absolutely
does go out the window and then all this
the way I was brought up like in school
I was in a school where I was like
loads of fights went on and and I was
always involved I got bullied in like
yeah seven year eight and then in year
nine I was like you know this is not
happening and then I became I just like
um develop like this Shield I'm going to
say and then of course I I reflect that
in my relationships but so with the baby
dad
it was horrible it was like that then
with the next partner I had he was he
was lovely I'm not gonna say he wasn't
but there was physical violence involved
the memory of both from both from both
so in the relationship I am now that
doesn't happen and here I am I'm like
okay
I need therapy and I'm taking it and you
know this I'm going to do my absolute
best on whatever it takes to make this
one work why because I have a man that
sees me the same way he knows my past he
knows all the madness he even knows I've
got a criminal record he knows that and
he's a record yeah and he accepts me and
he accepts me for that and he's like you
know I'm going to work with you because
I believe that that you can be this good
person and he knows that that deep down
I am and I and I you know I just want
the best for both of us so all this all
this BS that went on in the past
relationships I'm like okay that that
that and that that's not happening again
do you feel like because you're a woman
um when it comes to like physical abuse
that you get away with it more 100 100
and we [ __ ] we [ __ ] test men respect 100
we do that because I'm I'm I consider
myself a very feminine woman
so if I have a guy that gets into a
relationship with me
I need to know you are that man that's
gonna like hold me down because we do
need that we do need that um
sure yeah we we do need that I'm gonna
hold you down uh you're too feisty let
me hold you down girl because you ain't
going nowhere you know every now and
then I'm going to tell you what's what
and we like that but when we get a guy
that doesn't do that let me [ __ ] test
you and if one once twice three times
and then we just take you guys
I'm not going to say for granted but we
we [ __ ] about with you you know
I think I like I like what you're saying
because I think it shows that like you
you're aware of being a flawed person
and it's a it's a it's a way of speaking
I I almost never I'm generally shocked
you say a fraud person yeah like like
you're you're flawed like you're you
know you're cool with saying listen I
can be very physically kind of
domineering I can be aggressive if you
notice when you hear people talk about
these kind of women talk about these
kind they never say anything that you
know anything is on their part then the
idea is that they're perfect
not you but I'm saying like in general
it's always that the man's the bad guy
they're the victim can I can I just
answer the question before your
experiences
has it made you fair men
has it made me Fair men yeah do you fear
men no okay she's aggressively I don't I
don't feel much better I agree
he gave me a different type of
confidence and it's the thing where
I know that if I know that if I'm going
to fight a man he will he will [ __ ] me
up
but I'm still gonna give you my all you
know
yeah thank you but I know that
biologically I can't take on a man if I
was to go and find my boyfriend he he'll
pin me down and box me and knock me out
but I and I'm kind of thankful for that
because I now I don't like I don't see
myself being like like a little square
and scared to speak no I don't see
myself doing that so in a way it's good
but sometimes I go overboard and then I
just take it too far and then you know
like all these problems I've had in the
past
okay that is good can I just say
something I also don't fear men because
of my situation because I feel like when
you when you've already gone through so
much like crazy stuff you look at it now
and you've gone over it and you're now
it's normal it's nothing so like I said
I wouldn't girls you don't need to fear
men obviously they are physically more
they're stronger than you but what I
always say is if someone if a man was
coming coming to hit me I wouldn't even
hit him back to show him like I want to
hit you back if he hits me I'll just use
my my fluidity to fall a little bit more
and find ways to squirrel my way out of
it it's just don't be afraid just be
smart I fear women more than I fear man
me too I I think women are much scarier
yeah man absolutely that's why we're
here like I'm crazy no you're not crazy
I do I do I do Street interviews all the
time I've only been I'm like attacked or
like had someone try to attack me and
it's always been a woman oh wow yeah
like I had a girl they're like holding
her back she was trying to she was
trying to throw throw a punch at me and
like they were holding her back so she
wouldn't yeah she knocked the mic on my
out of my hand what did you say to her
no they took it down off of YouTube
somehow she got it taken down but it's
on Jessie praise's Channel going what
did you tell her did you report it sorry
that you experienced that but what did
you do
well wow so well she sucks so okay okay
this would happen I was I was doing
Street interviews and basically like
what what set her off was we were
talking about
how you're not entitled to safety and I
feel like as women like
it it's not smart to walk they always
use the example like well I can't walk
home alone at night and I'm like well
neither can men like why are you walking
home alone at night that sounds like a
stupid idea
cat dude either and so I just said like
why are you entitled to security and
safety like no one's ever had security
and safety in all of history ever but
you deserve it why and it'd be nice it'd
be it'd be a perk but like you want to
live in a big city that you chose to
anyway so this is why she got mad and so
then she's like you effing slag and I
didn't know what slag meant oh I didn't
know what that meant but I knew I was
being insulted
I'll have you use slag and like yeah and
then she like knocks the mic out of my
hand she's coming at me my friend
Jesse's like pulling her away so because
I brought a guy so like you know it's
mine yeah and
um yeah I did you know I called her a
whale but like what I said was a fact
she was a world okay yeah I mean like
let's see what's a heavyweight
well she was she was drunk as well
like that's that's where the whales
started yeah imagine the boys fighting a
lot of girl on girl boy on boy I feel
like the people feel like it's okay
because it's same same agenda so it's
not as bad yeah that's why sport is
divided in Sexes yeah I don't think
that's it's not good yeah but why like
okay if you went up to Dwayne The Rock
Johnson and you started something with
him and you got hit back no one would
really feel bad for you yeah why do we
feel bad for women if you hit him and
you start something and you get hit back
you started it yeah whoever started it
you started it that's your blame
absolutely yeah
you never meant he first mom taught me
that in school never he first believed
that he you hit double yes
equality so uh if a woman hits me then
you've just signed a consent form to be
hit back
that's how my son was raised yeah I have
I have no kind of I don't believe yeah
quality or not I'm I'm curious from them
as many of you know I was just banned on
Tick Tock and we are demonetized on a
daily basis on this platform if you want
to help please consider sending a super
thanks below every donation helps and it
helps make what we do possible